بكل نهايه عام بيكون لابرز الاحداث
الرياضيه اللي صارت على مدار السنه حصه
كبيره من الاخبار عام 2022 بدا بترحيل نجم
كره المضرب الصربي نوفاك ديوكوفيتش من
استراليا وسبب انه ما كان اخذ لقاح فيروس
كورونا وملزم كمان بالقوانين المفروضه على
الوافدين الموضوع نفسه كمان منعه من السفر
الى الولايات المتحده وحرموه من المشاركه
ببطوله الولايات المتحده المفتوحه وما
بدنا ننسى حدا كتير مهم بعالم الرياضه
كمان صار هاي السنه وهو استبعاد روسيا
وحلفتها بلا روسيا من الرياضه العالميه
والسبب اللي ما خلى روسيا تشارك بنهائي
كاس العالم ولا بلا روسيا بالعاب القوى
ومن عمليات الاستبعاد للفوضه اللي صارت
نهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا لكره القدم في 28
مايو بالعاصمه الفرنسيه باريس والفوضى كان
سببها انه الالاف من مشجعين ليفربول
الانجليزي ما ادري يوصلوا للملعب لحتى
يتابعوا المباراه ضد ريال مدريد الاسباني
وتعرض المشجعين او المشجعون همم من حاملي
التذاكر له هجوم كمان الغاز المسير للدموع
من قبل الشرطه وتهموا بمحاوله دخول الملعب
بشكل غير قانوني عموما يا جماعه بدايه
العام كانت بترحيله كوفيتش زي ما قلنا بس
انتهى بالحدث الاجمل وهي مباريات كاس
العالم واللي كانت مليئه بالمفاجات
افتتاحيه المباريات وما في شك انه كانت
بالفعل الاجمل كان في الفوز التاريخي اللي
حققه المنتخب السعودي على الارجنتين ليكون
وقتها ابطال الاخضر هما اول فريق بيهز
شباك مرمى الارجنتين وكمان الوحيد اللي
بيفوز عليه في كاس العالم مش بس هيك
المنتخب المغربي كمان حقك اكثر من فوز على
منتخبات عالميه وزائر اسود ما راح ينسينا
فوزه على اسبانيا والبر تونس كمان حققت
فوز نوعيه على المنتخب الفرنسي المصنف من
اقوى المنتخبات عالميا
من المنتخبات العربيه للاجنبيه فحقق
المنتخب الياباني فوز مستحق على المنتخب
الالماني وما بدنا ننسى طبعا فوز كرواتيا
على البرازيل اللي كان كفيل انه يبكي
نيمار ويستبعد فريق السامبا عن حلم كاس
العالم عموما احداث جدا شيقه تبعناها طوال
فتره المباريات بس المباراه النهائيه اللي
تواجه فيها فريق التانجو والارجنتيني مع
الديوك الفرنسيه كانت بالفعل حاميه الوطيس
وانتهت بفوز الارجنتين بضربات الترجيح بعد
ما كان التعادل هو سيد الموقف وهذا الفوز
حق اللاعب الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي حلمه
بوضع النجم الثالثه على شعار المنتخب
[موسيقى]